un ch'ti fissiles de révoquer la
citoyenneté d'un canadien donc depuis
2010 nous commençons à retirer le
processus à retirer la citoyenneté de
plus de 3000 personnes en 2012 plus 3000
canadiens étaient visés par des enquêtes
de fraude en matière de résidence trois
ans plus tard le ministère a finalement
révoqué la citoyenneté de 80 une
personne pourquoi une telle différence
d'abord après vérification beaucoup de
ces personnes étaient des immigrants
légitime alors arrêté au canada mais il
a vu recours aux services de consultants
en immigration qui ont fait l'objet d'
enquête et ensuite la procédure de
révocation que prendre des années avant
le dossier d'une personne soupçonnée de
fraude comporter trois étapes du bureau
du ministre puis la cour fédérale et
enfin le gouverneur en conseil depuis
les règles ont été simplifiées soit le
ministre peut décider de retirer la
citoyenneté un fraudeur
s'il ya cette preuve soit le cas est
complexe et la personne passe devant la
cour fédérale
si le ministère n'a pas révoqué la
citoyenneté des 3000 personnes visées au
départ le rythme des révocations
pourrait s'accélérer